let's say that this is me in this column
over here and that this is you and that
column over there and let's say that you
are in possession of a nice juicy of a
nice juicy Apple right over here so let
me draw this Apple properly let me make
the leaf in green so you are in
possession of this Apple and I'm hungry
I would like to have an apple and I just
assume well you possess this Apple I
assume that you own it so I go up to you
and say hey can i buy this Apple from
you and you say okay yeah I don't really
need it I'll sell it to you for a dollar
and so I give you a dollar I give you
one dollar and then you give me the
Apple and then you give me the Apple so
now I have it so now I have the Apple
somehow the Apple got smooshed a little
bit in the transaction so I so now I
have I have now I have the Apple now
when I did that transaction there were
some assumptions that were made I
assumed that possession of the Apple was
equivalent to ownership of the Apple I
assumed whoops I assumed possession is
equal to ownership and you might be
think well you know and what under what
cases would possession not be equal to
ownership well what if you just pick
this Apple from your neighbor's garden
the rightful owner of that Apple is your
neighbor but you just picked it maybe
you swipe this from the corner store
maybe you found this on a bench and you
said okay well doesn't seem an analysis
claiming it so I'm just going to clean
this Apple but maybe someone else had
left it on the bench and then they come
back an hour later said what happened to
my Apple I'm the owner of that Apple so
you see that differently even in the
case of an apple possession might not be
equal to ownership so these two things
might not be equivalent but for
something as small as an apple as I
guess you could say financially not as
important it was something that you know
has a market value of a dollar
it might be too much trouble to kind of
do a background check on the Apple to
see do a forensic analysis to see whose
garden the Apple came from or to see if
someone else had legal right
legal title to the Apple and so for
things like apples we tend to just
transact just assuming that possession
equals ownership now let's take let's
let's up the stakes a little bit instead
of an apple let's say we're talking
about a house so let's say that you are
in possession of this nice yellow house
so let me draw we definitely want to
visualize what a nice yellow house would
look like so it's got some windows here
so and there's some nice gardening
there's so you you are in possession of
this nice house so what does possession
of the house means well it means you're
living in it you have the keys to the
house your station wagon is in the
driveway your your stuff is in the
closet your furniture you have pictures
of you and your family on the wall so
you seem to be in possession of this
house and you stick a for sale sign out
on so--for for sale so you put a for
sale sign outside of this house and I'm
new to town and I need a place for me
and my family to live and so I say hey
you know I'd like to buy that house how
much is it and you say it's a hundred
thousand dollars say okay yeah she seems
like a reasonably good deal compared to
other houses in this neighborhood I want
to buy it and you say great so I walk up
to you I write a check for maybe I even
have cash for a hundred thousand dollars
so a little bit a little bit more
serious transaction than the Apple
transaction and then in exchange you
give me the keys to the house so now I
have the keys to the house and try to
draw some keys here so keys to the house
and you say just you know give me give
me an hour and you pack up all your
stuff take your pictures off the wall
put them in your station wagon and you
leave and you say okay well I guess I'm
just going to move into the house now
you probably are thinking something is
suspicious here something is makes us
feel a little less comfortable doing
this transaction than this transaction
over here because this house just
because the person happened to be in it
and had the keys to it didn't mean that
they own the house so once again
possession does not necessarily equal
ownership we can think of a lot of
scenarios for a house where possession
does not equal ownership they might have
been renting the house they might have
been renting they might have been guests
in the house and maybe the owners the
real owners were off to work and in
their faith their faces were the
pictures just because they were the
owners brother-in-law or something so
maybe they were guests in the house
maybe they were maybe they just saw a
vacant house maybe this is someone
else's vacation house and they said hey
you know what I know these people don't
show up during the summer so I'm just
going to go there change the locks have
the keys and I'm gonna pretend like I
live there and then I'm gonna try to
find somebody new to town and I'm going
to sell them the house for $100,000 and
if you think all of these things are
kind of crazy scenarios they've all
happened there because as you can
imagine there's some people for whom who
have who are I guess a little bit less
scrupulous who have who have whose
ethics are questionable who could be
very tempted by this so you can imagine
for when you're talking about big dollar
figures people have tried some fairly
major scams so how do you and you know
and once again just in the case of the
Apple maybe someone left it on the bench
and someone thought that it was there
you know you thought it was your Apple
now that you found it there could be it
doesn't have to be just scamming it
could be I thought I inherited this
house but then some other relatives
shows up who was closest closer to the
previous owner of the house it said no
no wait wait wait you can't give that
house you to the the son-in-law I am I
am the I am his younger brother or I am
his long-lost child or whatever else it
might be
so the you might have thought that you
owned the house but there might have
been some other claim on it and maybe
you bought the house outright or you
thought you bought it but maybe the
previous owner had you know that was in
a dispute with their brother or their
sister over the house so there could be
other claims on it and so the way that
the way in in in modern societies that
we deal with this where we see who has
ownership rights or another way of
thinking about it who has title so this
is important word who has title or I
guess you could say proof of title when
I talk about title
this is ownership right so we're talking
about real estate is the right to live
in the house it's the right to do what
you you know garden around the house
it's the right to
modify the house so the question of who
has title or evidence of title evidence
of title happens through legal documents
evidence of title and these legal
documents are called deeds so let me
write them so legal type these legal
documents are called deeds and deeds so
when I so if I wanted to buy this house
from you you would find you would we
would get a real get an attorney and
then we would draft a deed that
transfers that transfers the property
from you to me but you're saying maybe
that still doesn't you know prove to me
that that the house is all good and then
that's why I would do a title search on
it so there is actually companies that
do title searches and they're going to
go to the public records to the city or
county records and they're going to see
hey what are all the deeds that have
been filed with the city and whenever
there's a deed if it's things are done
properly it needs to be made a public
record it needs to be filed with the
city or county and so when you do a
title search so when you do just in a
different color when you do a title
search whoever is doing the title search
will look at the public records and
they'll look at all the previous DS
they'll then look they'll look at the
deed that that from the previous owner
of the house to you they look at the the
deed from from the previous owner even
before that and they'll make sure that
all of the the titles the the title
transfer has been cleaned that there
hasn't been any weird claims on the
house that there haven't been liens on
the house we'll talk more about what a
lien is a lien is essentially a claim on
the house maybe three owners ago someone
didn't pay property taxes in the city
still saying hey whoever owns this house
owes us a thousand dollars maybe four
owners ago there was someone who did an
improvement to the house and said hey
that owner never paid me for the new
driveway I have a lien on this house I
have whoever is benefiting from this
driver who owns this house they still
owe me money before I were to remove
that lien so the way that we do it in a
modern society is okay you say you're
selling this house but before I actually
give you the money
I'm going to do a title search I'm going
to make sure that there aren't any other
claims I'm going to make sure that you
are the real owner of the property and
only then will money be transferred